okay so good morning that was a really
great keynote from Julie I hope
everybody attended that you'll see some
similar themes through this talk as well
so I'm Randy sharp and I want to talk
today about moving fast at scale so I've
been doing software for 30 years
actually I had hair before I started
doing software so you know how old that
is these are the places that I've worked
in the last 15 years and I've taken away
learnings from all of them some of them
there's they're like learning things
that I should do and some of the things
that are learning things that I
shouldn't do I mean actually
interestingly I find that I learn more
from the failures than from the
successes and that's actually gonna be
something that we're gonna we're gonna
see going through here but what I want
to but what I want to do is talk about
what are the things that really
differentiate the high-performing
organizations from the from the less
well performing organizations in the
past here at build stuff I've talked a
lot about micro services and how to do
data and very sort of nuts and bolts
technical stuff this is not a technical
as much of a technical talk as it is a
talk about the earlier parts of the
product development process you know so
we'll talk about high performance
culture which i think is a core of doing
just about anything we're going to talk
about organization in the form of
autonomous teams we're gonna talk about
before we even write a line of code
defining what problem we're actually
trying to solve then as we go through
building our software I want to talk
about focus and prioritization and
finally I want to talk about how we can
build minimal viable features that are
sustainable for the long term so let's
start by talking about high performance
cultures so as Julia mentioned several
times the accelerate book this is a
fantastic set of research by Nicole for
syringe gene Kim and Jess humble really
well worth a read and one of the key
things that they talk about are three
different kinds of organizations so the
kind you want to be in is what's called
a generative organization and that's
characterized by trust and sharing so
this is where people within a team trust
one another and PTIN teams within the
organization trust one another as well
less exciting is to be in within a
bureaucratic organization I've
definitely been in one of those
where it's characterized by standards
and rules and processes and I've also
experienced this but you really don't
want to be in in this situation which is
a sort of pathological organization
where everybody's motivated by fear and
threat does anybody anybody had that
experience I definitely have in the past
yeah I'm sure not anywhere or that
you're working right now but you know in
the past before cool well so I want to
talk about some of the characteristics
of the generative organization which
hopefully you'll recognize so first off
I want to talk about some research that
started way back in 1960 by dr. Douglas
McGregor who wrote this wonderful book
called the human side of enterprise and
what he was trying to look at was
leadership's beliefs about what actually
motivates employees and he has a sort of
goofy names for them but I'll explain
them so he differentiates between theory
ex-leaders Theory acts organizations and
theory why what did what did he mean
when he said that
so Theory X is this idea that people are
inherently lazy they inherently try to
avoid responsibility they require
extrinsic motivation in other words they
need to be motivated by you know a
manager or a whip or something like that
and this tends to lend itself to
organizations that are very
micromanaging and very uncomfortable to
be in by contrast the theory why leaders
and the theory why organizations have
the belief that people are intrinsically
motivated they genuinely want to do a
good job they genuinely seek ownership
of the things they want to do and they
want to perform well and this wonderful
graphic which isn't mine also sort of
shows this the differentiation so in the
Theory X situation management's on the
top and it's kind of pushing down on the
staff yuck so it's very authoritarian
very repressive very tight control very
micromanage II theory why on the other
hand is way more what we might call
servant leadership so management is in
the bottom it's about liberating and
supporting and promoting the staff it's
about giving control to individual teams
rather than centralizing it and this
tends the theory why organizations tend
to perform a lot better
the other thing that's really important
about these generative and
high-performing organizations is this
idea of psychological safety and people
heard of psychological safety not enough
hands a good number but not enough so
great I'll tell you about it so Google
being Google did a bunch of research on
how on their individual teams and what
teams performed well and what teams
performed poorly and they had a bunch of
hypotheses going in where maybe it was
teams that had more PhDs on the team or
people that had been at Google longer or
something like that
it turns out that none of that stuff
matters at all what mattered more than
anything was this number one thing
called psychological safety and that's
the idea that the team trusted one
another or said another way the team
felt comfortable felt safe for
interpersonal risk-taking and the idea
is that people who feel comfortable
coming to their team and being able to
bring their whole self to work whether
it's you know their gender or their
sexual orientation or their politics or
all the aspects of their personality and
bringing that to the to their team
without fear of negative consequences
and this was more important than any
other factor in team success at Google
so this is a pretty powerful thing now
why do we think that might be its if I
can trust you to if I can trust that you
guys are gonna be nice to me and accept
me as a person I'm gonna be much more
willing to offer my honest opinions and
we're gonna be able to have a healthy
conversation and healthy debate a
healthy collaboration around the stuff
that we're building does it make sense
what I'm saying it's a fundamental core
idea to anything that we're gonna build
in terms of software organizations it
turns out these other five four things
are also really important again none of
these are number of PhDs number of years
at Google etc so all things that were
way better way more about culture than
they are about technology interestingly
enough the other thing I want to really
highlight is the best teams that I've
worked with do a lot of cross-functional
collaboration and in my experience the
best decisions that we make are made in
partnership between the business and the
product side and the technology side and
maybe the support side or the customer
side and it turns out to me it turns out
in my experience that once we agree on
the goals and priorities up front that
it's a lot easier for a
to figure out what tactics to do and and
when we don't when we tend to disagree
it usually is not because we have a
fundamental different view of the world
but we lack common context we lack
common context does it make sense what
I'm saying that when we have the same
information we tend to be able to have a
productive conversation it's when we
don't have the same information where
some of us know some things and the
others know other things that it isn't
as isn't as useful and then when not if
we have disagreements I love this idea
from Intel which they call disagree and
commits this is something from way back
in the 1970s the idea is that again with
psychological safety in our organization
I'm gonna make my pitch for the thing
that I'd like to do somebody else is
going to make their pitch we're gonna
agree on what we're gonna do and even if
we agreed on doing the other thing and
not my thing I'm gonna commit to making
that successful does it make sense so I
disagree but I'm gonna commit to making
it successful
and that's hugely important to an
organizational culture that's that's
really powerful I'm gonna give a
particular example from a time that I
was at Google so I was Iran engineering
for Google App Engine which is Google's
platform as a service and we had an
eight hour global outage where the
entire world of App Engine all over the
globe was out this was a very very bad
day and fall 2013 and it was basically
because of a bunch of legacy issues that
you know Julie was talking about earlier
where we had accumulated a bunch of
technical debt we had a bunch of
reliability issues that we had not
prioritized and it came back to bite us
in a big way
so because we had a generative
organization and we were pretty
collaborative we were able to sit down
and get all the stakeholders in a room
and sort of identify the problem this is
a sort of blameless post-mortem approach
to to approach to problem solving so we
had all the team leads all the engineers
but also all the product people and
business people etc all in a room and we
enumerated put up on the whiteboard
surrounding the room all sorts of known
issues that we had with reliable
reliability but also things that we
suspected might be problems as well and
we ended up by the end of the several
hours together
consolidating each of them into a eight
or ten different individual themes then
we assign those individual themes or
people volunteered to take those themes
forward and what we did is we time box
they're sort of additional research so
we said a week from today the same
people are gonna come back in this room
maybe some more people and we're gonna
talk about what we found talk about the
sort of research and thinking and
potential projects we might want to do
based on each of those individual themes
so a week later we all came back and as
a group at in a consensus way we
discussed all the stuff that we that
people had proposed we and we figured
out you know the small number of things
that we needed to do right away we
prioritized those and we got to work and
the and then the implementation sort of
a tactical part of it was pretty
straightforward so in division ears
worked on those assigned tasks to
improve various aspects of reliability
or system strength and it was very
minimal effort to manage it from the
manager perspective I was the manager
and it basically took me an hour a week
we just maintained a Google spreadsheet
with a line of like each person and what
they were working on it was super simple
super lightweight and we got a ton done
so the results were very quickly we had
we ended up having a 10x reduction and
the reliability issues that we've been
having before even more wonderful was
the effect on team culture so we had a
much broader participation and a much
broader kind of feeling of ownership
around those kind of reliability issues
because finally management was willing
to prioritize them finally we were
getting an opportunity to improve those
things we had a glut a much improved
cohesion and camaraderie among the team
and then when I get together with my
friends that we you know that we work
together on this we still all remember
that remember that reliability thing
that was really cool
so even out of crisis you can have
something that can change the culture
for the better and really improve things
so this I'm really proud of
so let's that was high performance
culture now let's talk about autonomous
teams so traditional organizations and
engineering like when I started 30 years
ago was there would be a couple a bunch
of people that would come up with an
idea so maybe we would call them the
business
or the product team or something like
that and they would throw their idea
over the wall to well-paid typists like
us so we would develop software we would
throw our software over the wall to
quality people who would try to figure
out whether we produce bugs or not and
then those and then we would finally
ship that software out to people that
would operate the software in the real
world what we have learned and the
research shows this is not a great way
to build software this silo hand off
silo hand off silo hand off much better
in modern organizations we do it like
this where we try to put in one team the
people that have the ideas the people
that do the development the people that
do the quality aspects of it and the
people that do the operations and by the
way those don't need to be separate
people it can be you know the same team
doing all those different things and why
do we and then we divide them up into
smaller teams rather than having one big
IT team and one big development team etc
and why do we do this it's so that we
can iterate faster right so we can we
can make these feedback loops much
shorter maybe one week or two weeks
rather than you know a year or two years
and we're able to make a lot more
progress and improve things a lot more
quickly it's really important that those
teams be small so people have probably
heard of this to pizza team idea to
pizza team yeah lots of nods that's
great thank you so it's actually
credited to Jeff Bezos the founder of
Amazon so he liked to say a team should
be fed it should be no larger than can
be fed by two large pizzas and you have
to sort of say to large American pizza
is to make that make sense I guess but
that's fine so that it tends to mean
like four to six people roughly as soon
as you get to have a team that's like
ten people or a larger you want to try
to see if you can split it up into two
smaller ones the other important thing
is that these teams need to be aligned
to particular problems in the business
so let's not have any more as we used to
have like the front end team the
application team the database team
why don't we want to do that it's
because every project would have to
cross every one of those team boundaries
so it makes sense instead let's have a
team that is autonomous that's able to
have all the skillsets altogether but
are aligned around a particular set of
business problems right so a particular
with
clear goals and metrics that actually
matter to our customers and then a well
and then a well-defined area of
technical responsibility that they're
responsible for so maybe one of those
teams is responsible for one or a few
applications one or a few services so a
relatively small amount of the overall
system but that is particular to one
particular area and as it engineering
leader myself the metric that I set for
myself is trying to see how can i form
the teams in a way that the vast
majority of their project work stays
within the team
does it make sense when I'm saying so if
it's something like maybe 20% of the
team's work is able to be done by
themselves and 80 percent of the time
they're having to coordinate with others
I didn't do my job and I didn't draw the
team boundaries in a very effective way
whereas if we flipped it around and the
VAT and the majority of the team's work
can be done without immediately all the
time coordinating with other teams then
I've done a good job of drawing those
boundaries does it make sense that I'm
saying yeah you could never get this to
a hundred percent because by definition
the big strategic priorities of your
company are almost by definition gonna
cross a bunch of teams so you're you
don't even want it to be a hundred
percent by the way because if you did
every team like literally is like their
own little company and there's no use
being all together does it make sense
that I'm saying so you definitely do
want a large scale things that you know
involve lots of different teams but in
an ideal world let's try to make the
teams be able to be autonomous and make
again lots of forward progress without
having to coordinate with with other
people cool so that was a quick
discussion of autonomous teams and sort
of what kind of organizations what kind
of organizational strategy works well
now I want to talk about something that
I think we don't we don't emphasize
enough in software which is defining the
problem that that we're working on so if
you remember nothing else out of this
presentation then I'd ask you to
remember these seven words and these
seven words are going to be so powerful
for you when you go back to your jobs
you know later this week or next week
and these seven words are what problem
are you trying to solve
this is a wonderful question you can ask
yourself in an introspective way but
this is also a wonderful question that
you can use when you're talking to those
idea people on your team so who has had
this experience where some person comes
to them and says hey can you guys just
add this button to the application yeah
let the record show that everybody's
nodding and even some hands went up
great so here's what you can say you can
say I would be very happy to do that but
please spend some time and tell me what
problem we're trying to solve
does that make sense so what you are not
saying is no I don't want to add your
button no I don't want to solve your
problem but instead but what you're
trying to do is start a dialogue where
instead of coming to the engineering
parts of the organization with a
solution add the button instead come to
us with a problem and then let's
collaborate and have a discussion about
how to solve the problem now it may well
be that adding the button is the right
solution there's nothing wrong with that
but it's important that we have that
conversation ahead of time now I'm not
suggesting that we do this for a week
like we could have this conversation for
15 minutes or 30 minutes something like
that just but it needs to be enough time
that you and and you can go away and
have a really good idea of the problem
that we're trying to solve so that you
can apply your creativity to solve it in
the best way and one of the things
that's really important that we bring to
that conversation that I think we under
emphasize or sort of under appreciate
about ourselves is we bring engineering
discipline so regardless of your you
know educational background by
practicing engineering in the real world
you have trained yourself to be
disciplined problem solvers does it make
sense like you're given a problem and
you break it down into smaller things
like first I'm gonna do this thing and
then I'm gonna commit it and then I'm
gonna do another thing and commit that
like our whole job is about taking some
big amorphous problem making it concrete
and dividing it into smaller steps
not everybody is trained in that in fact
few other people that are not that don't
have the daily practice of engineering
actually do this so in so the thing that
is our job in the conversation that I
just said about understanding the
problem is to help the person that we're
talking with help that support person
that customer that product person that
business person understand the problem
in the way that we would and and clarify
it does it make sense what I'm saying
this is the value that we provide we
provide that disciplined problem-solving
so as an engineer when I've had lots of
times in my career where you know
somebody's come and said hey please
Randy could you add this button or could
you
team at this button and what I go in my
head I say well here's what I would have
done I would have thought about the
problem I would have thought about all
the different you know four or five
different possible solutions I would
have thought about the different
trade-offs and then I would have decided
okay the button is the right way to go
and then I would have proposed it does
anybody think that that's what that
person actually did
no probably not right and that's what
you can help them to do with your 5
minute or 15 minute or 30 minute
conversation does it make sense like
that you're helping yourself understand
the problem you're helping them refine
the problem and you're gonna build
better software by taking that time to
do it
great the other thing that we need to
bring to that conversation is something
that is something that's called the
curse of knowledge so this is just a
natural part of being human that if I
understand something I think that you
understand it - and that's the curse
aren't the curse of our knowledge is
when when we when I hear Randi please
add that button I go oh man Wow here's
all the different things that is
associated with that I'm sure that
person has thought about it but like I
have all these options and trade-offs
and implications in my head oh that's
going to add to the technical debt load
that we have oh that's going to make it
much more difficult to roll out oh
that's gonna screw with the user
experience of that page you see what I
mean there's all these different
trade-offs that I have in my head and
it's my job to say them out loud so the
other person knows those too
does that make sense so again helping
helping that other person to go through
that discipline problem-solving process
but also helping them to understand the
engineer things that you know and you
might assume that they know but they
actually don't so it's our job to bring
that to the conversation great so this
is a good start - this is a good set of
reasons why we want to clarify the
problem that we're trying to solve there
are some other reasons too so Marian top
pop and dick 15 years ago wrote this
fantastic book coxy sixteen years ago
wrote this fantastic book called lean
software development if you read it now
you would think that it was written in
2019 rather than 2003 it was so
prescient so incredibly modern the only
thing that doesn't look modern is like
the code you know the examples of the
particular software that they're using
but and they and they identify seven
different wastes in software development
the number one waste is building the
wrong thing so the critical thing that
we need to do up front is understand the
problem that we're solving so that we
make sure that we're building the right
thing rather than the wrong thing and
there are lots of ways to be inefficient
in software like I've done lots of
inefficient things but if I'm building
the wrong thing it's like a hundred
percent of my effort is wasted it makes
sense so really important to think
upfront and make sure that we that we
really understand our problem okay so if
you're not convinced yet hopefully this
guy from General Motors Charles
Kettering many years ago said this a
problem well stated is a problem half
solved that's why we do that discipline
problem solving for our for our part
because it helps us to break the problem
down make it more incremental to solve
and so again that problem definition
process helps us in our daily job as
well it is very important so Julie had
Julian the keynote had this thing where
she where she said something like she
really liked deleting code except were
paid to write code I think she was
wonderful and that was a very clever
thing to say but I don't think we're
paid to write code I
were paid to solve problems a lot of the
times we solved the problem by writing
code but lots of other times we can
solve it an entirely different way so
when I used to work for stitch fix which
is a clothing retailer in the United
States we had physical warehouses all
around the country and one of my teams
wrote software for the physical
warehouses and so a bunch of times we
would have the warehouse people come to
us and suggest improvements to the
applications they were absolutely
fantastic work with by the way and
sometimes we would say oh let's fix the
application in this particular way but
many times we would go through that kind
of discipline problem-solving process
with them and we would figure out oh you
know what if we just simply change the
fund the underlying business process we
wouldn't have to write any new code and
it would actually be a lot simpler does
it make sense what I'm saying like this
is our value our value is not just being
a well paid typist it is solving
problems and sometimes we solve those
problems by writing code
okay sometimes who solved those problems
by deleting code too great okay so we
talked about culture we talked about
organization we talked about the thing
we all really ought to be doing which is
refining and defining the problem ahead
of time before we do before we do
anything now let's talk about focus and
prioritization and this is about how
we're gonna execute in the real world
so again tradition traditional
organizations or traditional approaches
to teams are kind of like this and I
will admit that as a team leader I've
done this many times so okay so I had
this huge pile of features that I need
to do and hopefully they're in some kind
of priority order and my backlog or
something like that and I have five
people on the team and I have more than
five things to do so let's see I'll just
put person one on feature one person two
on feature two person three on feature
three etc and maybe in this made-up
example it's gonna take us four months
to ship something this seems very
natural like there's tons of stuff to do
let's just get started on all of them it
turns out this is actually not a great
way to run anything particularly a
software project so we'll talk about
some ways we can make this better
so the first thing that we want to do oh
yeah if you if you if you're willing to
take away more than those initial seven
words then maybe you could take away
four more and try these four so try
taking away this idea of doing fewer
things more done fewer things more done
so what do I mean by that so let's take
that same five person team and those
same features and instead of spreading
you know the people very wide and
working on five things at once what if
we worked on the highest couple of
features first and maybe we put several
people on them now this assumes that you
know will be valuable you know that two
people could actually be productive on
feature one let's just assume that for
the moment that's not true of everything
but it's true of a lot of things to be
honest so maybe let's have two people
work on feature one let's have two
people work on feature two and then the
the other person can work on feature
three and then when those pairs of two
you know get done with feature one and
feature two maybe they can start on
feature four and feature five does this
make sense now
I do here instead of delivering instead
of waiting for four months or whatever
to deliver any value to my custard
customers at all
now I'm delivering value at month two
and which value am i delivering I'm
delivering the highest priority stuff
makes sense so already I've made a huge
difference in terms of providing value
to my customers more quickly than I
otherwise would okay I think we can do
even better though so what if instead of
releasing the feature as one big
monolithic thing what if we thought a
carefully upfront and tried to break it
down into smaller increments right so
what if we instead I'm making this up
but what if we instead broke feature one
down into four incremental smaller
releases we broke feature two down in my
example into three incremental releases
etc and this does take a little bit of
thinking upfront but it has the
wonderful advantage of now I've
delivered incremental pieces of value
maybe not in two months but maybe every
two weeks something like that it also
allows us to get much tighter feedback
so we've released something and we can
see whether it works even if it's not
even released to customers we can see
that it's integrated that it's
interacting successfully with the rest
of the system we can see that it's
performing well there are lots of things
that we can do that we can learn and
optimize for by doing these tiny
individual releases it also makes us
much more much more resilient to this so
who has ever started a piece of software
and before they were able to finish and
release it the priorities changed
let the record show that almost every
hand went up cool so the wonderful thing
about delivering smaller units of work
fewer things more done or in lean
terminology reducing whip limits
reducing work-in-progress or smaller
batch sizes by reducing by producing
smaller units of work it allows us to be
resilient to changes in priorities
because even if we get shifted on to
something else which is legitimate maybe
there is a higher priority in the in the
company there's nothing wrong with that
it's just at least we've provided value
does it make sense
when we're in this situation
time before month four we have produced
exactly zero value
exactly zero the only value that we
produce when we're doing the software
part of our problem solving is when we
actually ship software and consumer and
customers use it in the real world right
everything along the way until we get to
that point is useless
okay
great okay so let's summarize what we
learned about this and by the way we're
just like read arriving agile and lean
principles from first principles and I'm
using trying to use simpler language so
what have we done so instead of having
five people work on five things in
parallel and treating the priority five
one with the same amount of you know
effort as the priority one what if
instead we delivered the highest
priority features first and we treated
the priority one one is actually the
highest priority and we worked on that
first and then we got it done and we did
something else we've delivered our full
value earlier so the full value of that
feature one and a full value of feature
two we actually ship those to customers
in this example you know with half the
time and as you're probably know from
you know economics like a dollar or a
euro today is worth more than a dollar
or a euro in a month or in a six months
or a year and that same is true with
software once when we int when we
introduced that incremental delivery
idea we delivered value along the way so
we delivered increments of value instead
of you know queuing everything up and
delivering it all in one big chunk at
the end and it also allowed us to
deliver value more efficiently because a
lot of times when I am pairing with
somebody else when I have two people
whether we're using one keyboard or
separate keyboards whatever but when two
of us are working on the same thing we
can unblock each other can't we like
when I reach a point where I'm not sure
how to move forward I can have a
conversation with my partner and she can
often unblock me and maybe I can unblock
her when she gets blocked does it make
sense what I'm saying like having have
sometimes not always but sometimes two
heads really are better than one great
so I want to give two real-world
examples from eBay about how we well we
did this how we prove it produced
incremental value that added up to
something really big so the first
example is what's called machine learned
ranking so when I was at eBay I helped
build eBay search engine and people are
probably familiar by using a search
engine that a search engine has what's
called a ranking function so that's the
that's the function that scores the
results and decides what thing to put in
you know the first position in the
result
what thing to put in the second position
third position etc right that's the
thing that figures out what to order
it's called the ranking function and the
earlier part of eBay was basically a
handwritten you know very simple ranking
function that was handwritten by a
product manager and it was pretty good
it lasts for years and years and years
but our our hypothesis was that if we
somehow could use instead of a handful
of factors and some we said could if we
could use thousands of factors we could
actually produce better results
that was our that was our guess so we
did a whole bunch of experimentation we
built some predictive models to help us
figure out when people were looking for
something on eBay how often would they
actually go view the item when people
viewed the item how often would they
actually go and purchase it and we did a
bunch of stuff to figure out what things
would predict those those steps in the
in the purchase process and we we ended
up doing a hundreds and hundreds of
parallel Abie tests we're changing
different factors and different weights
for things and we did a full year of you
know each individual improvement was not
that big it would be like 0.01 percent
or something like that barely noticeable
but it was actually noticeable and by
adding you know a point oh one percent
here to 0.01 percent there and we add
that up over a year we ended up driving
with this project alone a two percent
increase in the overall revenue of the
eBay company which at the time was sixty
billion US dollars a year so this effort
added a hundred and twenty million u.s.
dollars to the bottom line right there
that was pretty cool
and again know one thing made a massive
difference it was the practice and the
process of incrementally trying this
thing that didn't work trying this thing
that didn't work oh that thing does work
okay let's Bank that you know 0.01
percent of improvement and then try
something else try singing else try
something else it make sense like very
very incremental improvements which
added up to something really big at the
same exact time as we were doing this
another one of my teams was improving
the performance of the pages themselves
so the hypothesis was that our
hypothesis as engineers was that
we made our pages faster people would
buy more and as a side note we actually
had a really difficult challenge
convincing the business that we should
make the existing features faster rather
than adding new features and so we we
said like please trust us I know it
feels like we should add more features
but just trust us give us some
opportunity to try to make the existing
features faster and we think it's going
to make a big difference so again we
went through a very iterative
experimentation process where we would
implement a potential improvement we
would do an a/b test where we would have
the old version of the site for some
users the newer version of the site for
other users and we would monitor all the
metrics that you know the revenue and
and more technical details about page
rendering and so on and at the end of
this process we again got another 2%
increase in the overall revenue so
another 120 million US dollars and each
of these was maybe was a couple of teams
involved maybe 15 people in total
involved in the machine learn ranking
and maybe another 10 or 15 across a
couple of teams in this one so not a
huge not a huge investment but like a
really huge payoff and this again in
both these cases there was no one magic
bullet there was just slow incremental
progress banking that and then
continuing to move forward make sense
cool okay so the last thing that I want
to talk about is the discipline that we
have or when we're actually building
features and the way people have
probably heard of this idea of the
minimal Viable Product I want to take
that same idea but I want to apply it a
little bit you know more targeted and a
more targeted way to features so who's
ever heard this we don't have time to do
it right
yes knowing laughter many hands lots of
nods yes I think we've all heard that so
here's another tool in your engineer
toolbox you can use do we have time to
do it twice
because that's pretty much that's pretty
much the the option here and
interestingly enough I off so I've
worked at a couple of startups in
addition to the big companies and I've
heard oh we don't have time to do it
properly because we have so much to do
and I find that odd because if you take
a step back and you think about it
almost the more constrained we are in
time and resources the more important it
is that we get the one thing that we're
working on and we get it done and what
I'm not saying is got it done perfectly
and we're never gonna have to change it
again ever but what I am saying is like
let's get it solid so we can leave it
aside and work on the next thing makes
sense what I'm saying and so I like to
think about this as the minimal viable
feature and all of these three words are
really important the minimal part like
what's the simplest stupidest most
straightforward way we can solve the
customer problem with this feature and
let's just do that get it out there and
get feedback viable so it has to be like
actually has to actually work it
actually has to be reliable it has to I
have to be able to like forget about it
it makes sense like it has to be viable
in the real world it doesn't have to be
super pretty it can be a little bit you
know we're just trying stuff out but it
has to be viable and then of course it
has to be an actual feature that solves
a customer problem so what do I and
interestingly your customers will thank
you for this so all of us carry these
super supercomputer I'd put it away but
all of these carry us all of us carry
these little supercomputers around in
our pockets that we call our mobile
phones when the last time that you
updated your you know mobile phone
operating system you know probably you
do that regularly I probably did you say
wow there are 57 new features in you
know iOS 13 that's so awesome yeah said
nobody ever what you are actually
interested in is the one or two or three
features that actually matter to you
like oh there was a real there's a great
update to this app that I use all the
time the battery life is better
so make sense like the quantity of
features like nobody is measuring us on
the quantity of features or to be
precise no customer is measuring us on
the quantity of features what they are
though is measuring us on the quality of
features that we do build ok so I like
to build one thing that is done or you
know at least minimally viable rather
than two half-finished things and I want
to be super clear that what I'm not
saying is done is perfect I'm saying
that it's done enough so that it works
and I can move on to the next thing
so it's really more about the 80/20 rule
like what's the 20% of effort that I can
put in to get 80% of the benefit and
when not if when we have many things
that we want to do it's way more
important that instead of reducing the
quality of the things that we produce we
just reduced the scope like instead of
trying to produce ten different things
that are not that great let's produce
five things that are pretty solid and
then we can work on the next five things
that make sense
so the Keith the the idea here that
comes from agile is having a definition
of done so when I say done what do I
mean so what would be a minimal Viable
feature okay so the first thing is like
the part of the feature the like feature
part the actual functionality that we
want to deliver to customers so let's
deliver a minimal Viable Bible feature
there I for sure want to have automated
tests associated with it again I want to
be able to like leave it aside not have
to worry about it so I can focus fully
on the next thing has to be released to
production I can't tell you how many
times I've had conversations with
engineers on my team or others where I
said oh you know how how is it going on
XYZ thing that you're working on like oh
I'm done is it released yet oh no it's
not released okay you're not done or
we're not done
and then I've you know other things
we're okay are how are we doing on XYZ
feature
oh it's released great well did we turn
the feature flag on so if customers are
using it oh no we haven't we haven't
done that yet like okay we're not done
and then similarly if I've released it
to production and I don't have any way
of sustainably monitoring it and
understanding whether the features
working or not whether it's being used
or not it's also not done does it make
sense again coming back to that earlier
earlier idea we are not done until there
is actual value that we've delivered to
customers it makes sense like nothing
matters until we actually ship something
okay cool I do want to talk a bit here
about the huge power of test-driven
development so at several of the
companies that I worked for we had
really strong test-driven development
cultures my particular part of Google I
was really good at that stitch fix where
I worked was really strong in that as
well
and to the potential skeptics whether in
the audience or people that you work
with we don't write tests to go slow we
write tests to go fast and what we're
doing is we're making an investment
upfront in our ability to do the next
job and the next job in the next job by
simply writing some automated tests for
this feature
so I basically don't have to worry about
it again it makes sense so when I'm
making changes in some other area of the
code I know at least that I haven't
broken this thing because I haven't
broken my tests I live in California and
I live near the coast and I like to go
running and so sometimes I like to go
running on the beach it's really slow
and really hard to run on the beach
because the sand keeps slipping out from
under your feet it's much easier to run
on solid ground your tests are the solid
ground of your software that makes sense
it allows you to go faster exactly
because the stuff that you're doing
isn't breaking anything cool and again
your tests are your are your safety net
to catch again when you might when you
might break things tests also make
better code because to Julie's point yes
in her keynote about refactoring it
gives us the confidence to like
radically potentially radically refactor
areas because we know that the tests are
going to catch it if we break something
and
the courage to do that really well and
also tests make better systems because
they allow us to catch bugs not at the
time that we've shipped them to
customers but much earlier in the
development process when it's a lot
easier to fix them it makes sense so if
you and your collaborators aren't
convinced yet
think about what developers actually do
every day so this is a 2006 study from
Microsoft it's probably pretty accurate
today and this is what we actually do
day to day so you might think that we're
adding new code all the time turns out
that we're not really doing that we're
spending 75% of it particularly in
legacy systems maybe even more 75% of
our time reading and understanding
existing code maybe 20% of the time
modifying that existing code and maybe
only five percent of the time writing
new code now your numbers might be
different but I guarantee you you're
reading existing code a lot more than
you are writing new stuff and it turns
out that test-driven development helps
with both of these things right it helps
us to read existing code because tests
are executable documentation and it
certainly helps us modifying existing
code but because it makes sure that we
don't break things it actually also
helps us write new code but I'm happy
with 95%
cool okay so at stitch fix again we we
had a very strong test-driven
development culture and as a consequence
we basically didn't really have a bug
tracking system now we produced a plenty
of bugs like it's not like we were
magical software developers we were very
average to be perfectly honest but the
process allowed us that when we found
when we've produced a bug we would
typically find it pretty early in the
development process and even if we did
find a bug that was released to
customers we hadn't accumulated such a
massive backlog of bugs that we could
just fix it
right oh that just came up great okay
I'm gonna stop what I'm working on now
I'm gonna fix that bug and then I'm
gonna go back to it and you could do
this to like these weren't magical
people with some magical different kind
of software than everybody else this was
very straightforward regular people with
regular software working in the regular
world and the only difference or the
major difference was this discipline
around test-driven development I can't
tell you how powerful it is and it
allows us to turn what can often feel
like a vicious cycle of like oh man
we've got a bunch of technical debt we
don't have time to do it right so we put
in some quick and dirty hack so we
accrue more technical debt so it makes
it even harder to do it right the next
time round and round around and gets
worse and worse and instead by adopting
you know I think minimal viable features
incremental deployment test-driven
development we could have a solid
foundation which gives us the confidence
to write really good software really
simple software allows us to be faster
and better we can do more investments in
the testing and the development process
and we can we can have a virtuous cycle
okay so we talked about the base I think
the culture which I think is really
important high performance culture we
talked about organization in the form of
autonomous teams we talked about making
sure we really define the problem that
we're solving up front we talked about
focus and prioritization of where we put
our resources we finally talked about
minimal viable features and strong
development practices and so again by
reference back to the accelerate book
they make a distinction between sort of
low performers medium high and what they
call elite and so the difference between
the elite performers and the low
performers are that the elite performers
are releasing code deploying code 46
times more often their lead time the
time between when I commit my code to
source control and it actually gets
deployed on site is 2500 times faster in
these elite organizations they have a
seven times lower change failure rate so
the amount of time that when I ship
something a production that I have to
roll it back or hot fix it or something
like that
seven times less and also 2600 times
faster time to recover from incidents
so these techniques really do matter in
the engineering metrics that we care
about every day but even more
importantly they care they matter in the
business metrics so the other thing that
this research shows is that that's those
same high-performing organizations are
two and a half times more likely than
the low performers to exceed business
goals like profitability and market
share and productivity so it doesn't
just matter to engineers it also matters
to businesspeople into the into the
company itself so thank you very much
[Applause]
okay all right so a couple I'm not sure
how long we have for questions but I'm
sure they'll stop me when applying the
iterative approach and only doing
minimal improvements how do you decide
when to stop that is a great question
you decide when to stop when you're no
longer producing customer value that
matters so I think probably something
that I should have said is making sure
that we have metrics that decide at
least whether our feet what no and limit
when our features or whether our
features are being used but also like
what value they're actually providing
and so we stopped when the incremental
cost of producing a feature is more than
the value then we're gonna get does that
make sense
cool one more did you put in an oak do
you put any okay ours when starting to
work on search improvements if yes how
did you come out with a predicted number
so that's a great question
let's see we we did have goals we didn't
have formal okay ours at eBay but that's
not the important part of the question I
think what you're asking is did we know
we were gonna get the two percent
improvement like no we did not we just
had a hypothesis that we could make an
improvement in the revenue and the usage
of the search pages by again having the
ranking be better and by making the
pages faster we had no idea to be frank
when we started whether we were going to
get 0.1% improvement for revenue or one
or two we we had a pretty good idea that
since we'd never done any work on
performance or any work on the ranking
improvements before that there was a lot
of room for opportunity but we really
didn't know ahead of time what we were
going to get